but i have to ask you this because joe
biden is now president and i heard him
say i know it's exciting um but i
thought it was still out i
thought there was no conceding no no no
he wasn't i was there in the office with
him okay great oh that's right
i was and he did say that will and grace
did more than anything else to shift
like
how people viewed gay marriage yeah and
i never really thought about that but i
think that's
absolutely true especially reaching on a
broad
scale like so many you're in the homes
of you know all across america
i mean look i got the when i got the
pilot which is the first episode i was
27 years old
yeah so just a couple of years ago but i
um
thanks that took just a second
but um no and i was just happy to get a
job on a tv show i had no idea that the
byproduct would be something that was
bigger than all of us
and then i'm sitting at home on the
couch one day i remember this is when
joe biden was the vice president
and he said something on uh msnbc or i
don't know some show
and he was like will and grace did more
to educate america about the gay
movement than anything and i was like
what
like i think i'm sure though art does
inspire like
real life like i think i'm a real life
inspires art i guess chicken yeah but
but
yeah i i think it's absolutely true i
just never thought about it also it's
the power of comedy
it's the power of comedy is is the
ability to educate people without them
knowing it because if they're enjoying
you
there's no you can't yeah you can't
combat that
right i agree right yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
help